Candid Truth.
>> Hello everybody. Um, we're back at it at
Candid Truth. Sorry about the low
quality. We are traveling right now. We
don't have our full set, but just bear
with us. We needed to cover this topic.
I've been had it prepared and I need to
cover it just to get it out and um I've
worked hard on it. So, without further
ado, let's go ahead and get into it.
All right. The whole point is, of
course, we need to know what the Bible
says about this. How how is this godly
or not? So,
let's take a look at what I found. What
I found is that it's about a lot of
angelic revelation.
The book of Enoch is one long angelic
encounter. It says with um I I don't
know if I'm going to say this right,
Ariel, Raphael and others leading Enoch
through cosmic tours and heavenly
secrets. In the Bible in John 14:6, it
says, "I am the way, the truth, and the
life." This is Jesus speaking, "No man
comes to the father but by me." So, this
does seem to already
in some ways,
I'm not going to say fully, but in some
ways this is a little bit different
because it's not through angelic
encounters that you come to Christ and
the truth. Um, it's through Jesus.
And it also says in Isaiah 45:1 19, I
have not spoken in secret in a dark
place of the earth. I said not unto the
seed of Jacob, seek ye me in vain. I the
Lord speak righteousness. I declare
things that are right. So he says he
declares it not as a mystery basically
or secret.
The other thing I found is in first
Enoch 8 verse 1-3 the fallen angel Aazil
teaches men to make swords, ornaments,
makeup, enchantments, and astrology to
learn about astrology. That's not divine
revelation.
It seems that even if the fallen angels
did give that knowledge to mankind, it's
the same forbidden knowledge type of
blueprint of occult religions and
witchcraft. We should not be looking to
these entities or learning from them if
it is indeed a cult or witchcraft.
Because in Proverbs 2:6 it says, "For
the Lord gives wisdom. From his mouth
come knowledge and understanding.
Also in Deuteronomy 18:10-12,
there shall not be found among you
anyone who practices divination or
sorcery.
It seems that there might be
contradiction here. I think there is
that the forbidden knowledge from these
angels and so on. This idea of the book
of Enoch is a a kind of a forbidden
knowledge that they're going to expose
to you is described in elaborate detail.
It's not just con
condemning things and explaining to you
like this is bad. The book of Enoch
lists the names of fallen angels. It um
is revered highly and describes exactly
what they taught such as herbs,
weaponry, enchantments, astrology, etc.
This serves more like a grimoire, a book
of spells usually and magic in
witchcraft, a manual of forbidden arts
than a warning.
It gives people a recipe for how to
follow witchcraft and then says don't if
you're saying don't do this, it's
spiritually dangerous.
The Bible teaches that Christ is the
mediator between God and man in 1
Timothy 2 verse 5. While Enoch presents
angels as mediators and teachers of
salvation through hidden wisdom,
this seems like it's angel worship then
the same thing Paul warns against in
Colossians 2 verse 18. The focus is on
angelic secrets,
not on repentance or redemption.
That's not revelation.
That's deception then.
But furthermore onto the second point
which might be in my estimation is
weightier and of more notable
recognition is that in the occult
the book of Enoch is
actually used. It's referenced and the
first place it would be is going back to
the Alexandrian connection. Most of us
forget Alexandria the island of
Alexandria where the occult libraries
and knowledge was held.
and one would say the birthplace of the
counterfeit faith. Many settled in
Alexandria, Egypt, where they
established schools of occult knowledge
that would later influence world
empires. This was not the faith of
Abraham or the prophets. It was the
continuation of Babel's rebellion under
a new name. In Alexandria, these
sorcerers found refuge and recorded
their forbidden arts into manuscripts.
They became part of the famed library of
Alexandria, a hub of every form of
esoteric science, astrology, alchemy,
and idolatrous philosophy.
Out of that corrupted stream rose the
Pharisees and Sadducees, religious
leaders who exalted man-made tradition
and mystical interpretation over the
written word of God.
>> [clears throat]
>> Jesus exposed them directly in John
8:44, saying, "You are of your father,
the devil." Their system was not the
light of Moses, but the darkness of
Babel reborn.
Intellectual, ritualistic, and
spiritually blind is really what Babel
was. So when we trace the book of Enoch
back to its Alexandrian environment,
we're tracing it to the same pit that
birthed every counterfeit religion
and can be called cabalism in some
cases. It does resemble other um occult
teachings as well, but is the center of
satanic philosophy
where fallen angel worship and hidden
wisdom replaced obedience to the word of
God.
It was never the voice of heaven. It was
the whisper of Babylon coming back.
Number three, it's the backbone of a
cult and satanic systems. We're going to
flesh it out this time
deeply. Let's name names. Alistister
Crowley used in magic. Again, if you are
here for the first time, magic with a K
is not just magic. It is sexual magic.
Inakian magic is a structured system of
ceremonial magic developed originally by
John D and Edward Kelly in the 16th
century. They claimed to have
communicated with angels who revealed a
divine language in a set of keys and
calls and the 30 ethers spiritual realms
which through which a m magician could
ascend.
The system includes a special angelic
language called Enochian, ritual tables
which are elemental tables called the
great table as well and evocations to
open gates to spiritual realms.
The 30 ethers each a realm that the
magician explores via scrying,
invocation, and spirit uh sorry symbolic
ritual.
What are the aethers more in depth?
Well, the word aether
spelled ae e t h h h h h h h h h h h h h
h h h h h h h h h h h h h h h h h h h h
h h h h h h h y y r or a e t h e r
literally means upper air or spiritual
atmosphere. So, ether.
Anyone think of the prince of the air
for the name of Satan?
I did. But in a cult usage, it refers to
layers or levels of invisible realms.
what Enochian magicians believe are 30
plains of existence between earth and
heaven. Each aether is said to be ruled
by specific angels or spirits and
magicians like Alistister Cwley used
trance rituals to open these ethers one
by one supposedly ascending through
spiritual dimensions.
Crowley described these ethers in the
vision and the voice
as I'm guessing that's a book of his as
portals that reveal hidden wisdom and
angelic truths. But biblically speaking,
this is just contacting fallen spirits.
A modern rebranding of ancient Babel
style spirit ascension.
Isaiah 8:1 19 warns against this
directly. It says, "Should not a people
seek unto their God? Should they seek
unto the dead on behalf of the living?"
In other words, they should only be
contacting God or going after and
seeking God for answers. They should not
be talking to the dead.
Opening the ethers is precisely that,
seeking revelation from spiritual beings
instead of God.
And what are these ritual tables and the
great table mentioned?
These are m magical diagrams used as
maps and keys for summoning or invoking
spirits. The elemental tables are four
large squares filled with mysterious
letters, each representing an element,
air, water, earth, and fire. Like
witches, they call upon them as well as
gods. Each table is said to hold the
names of angels and spirits controlling
that element.
The magician calls these beings using
inakian keys, spoken incantations, in
other words, to command access to their
realm.
The great table or also called the table
of union. This combines all four
elemental tables into a master diagram
supposedly representing the structure of
the entire universe. The great table
acts as a cosmic map. Each line and
letter corresponds to an angelic
governor of the spiritual plains.
By tracing or gazing upon these diagrams
while in reciting in invocations,
practitioners believe they can open
gates into the invisible world. that is
the ethers.
So in plain terms, the elemental tables
and the great table are ritual
blueprints for opening portals to spirit
realms through invocation.
It's the same principle ancient
magicians used with engraved amulets or
talismans, a visual key combined with
spoken words to unlock communication
with spirits. So Enochian magic is not
biblical Christian theology. It is an
occult system of angel invocation and
spiritual ascent anchored in angelic
revelation and mystical cosmology.
How Crowley used it? Crowley's key work
is the vision and the voice that comes
from Liieber page 418. He chronicled his
scrying of the 30 acres in Mexico
and Algeria. Oh, in Mexico in 1900 and
Algeria in 1909. The subtitle of his
work reads, "Being of the angels of the
30 ethers." So, he's communicating with
beings or a being.
In his system, Crowley believed the
practitioner could ascend the ethers,
eventually crossing the abyss and
becoming a master of the temple in the
city of the pyramids.
He defines magic with a K, sex magic, as
among other things, the science and art
of, and I quote, let's just start again,
the science and art of causing change to
occur in conformity with will.
And he says also, magic is getting into
communication with individuals who exist
on a higher plane than ours.
Crowley's intention was
self-deification.
We did see that in the last slide where
it says down below the very last
sentence, he wanted to eventually cross
the abyss and become a master of the
temple in the city of the pyramids.
So let's go back down to where we were.
His intention was self-deification to
become like gods to command an angelic
or spiritual beings to traverse the
spiritual hierarchy and claim divine
status or at least divine power. Exactly
the same lies from heaven or sorry from
the garden where it was said that you
could become like God.
Number four, what I found is it's the
same spirit behind modern sorcery and
angel angel light movements. Today's
Enoch lovers include new age channelers
claiming to talk with Ariel or Raphael,
and many others, Tik Tok witches invol
invoking watcher energy, UFO and
Nephilim cults mixing Genesis with alien
theology,
and Paul warns us. He says, "Avoid
profane and vain babblings and
oppositions of science falsely
so-called." That's in 1 Timothy 6:20.
This fascination with hidden truths and
celestial hierarchies isnosticism
resurrected.
It is the same deception the apostles
fought constantly in the Bible.
The contradiction is that the Bible
teaches open revelation through Christ,
not secret revelation through angels.
This comes especially from Hebrews 1
1-2.
God reveals himself plainly. Occult
systems hide him behind passwords,
sigils, rituals, I'll add, and angelic
languages. That's not light. That's
Lucifer's imitation of light.
So number five, God himself condemns the
source. In 1 Enoch 10:es
4-5, it says, "Bind Aazil hand and foot,
cast him into the darkness."
You see, and even inside Enoch, God
punishes the angels for revealing
knowledge.
Yet people still read it to learn from
the watchers, as they call them. That's
like studying Satan's fall. Listen to
this. It's like studying Satan's fall to
find enlightenment yourself.
Should not a people seek their God
again? Should they seek the dead on
behalf of the living? Once again, we are
to seek God and God alone.
Contradiction.
The Bible says God alone is the source
of wisdom. In James 1 vers5,
the watchers wisdom quote unquote caused
corruption, war, and vanity. The very
sins that filled the earth before the
flood, the very things that we still
consider sins today.
And it says in Genesis 6:5,
"And God saw that the wickedness of man
was great."
Extra proof is that in theosophy and the
new age and ascended master teaching it
is mentioned.
Madame Bllovotsky once again Luciferian
founder of theosophy referenced Enoch
constantly
calling it a reliable source of ancient
wisdom. Alice Bailey who formed Lucius
Trust
praised Enoch's model evangelic
lightbringers as part of the great white
brotherhood.
The ascended masters like Senat Kumara,
Dual Coul
etc. claim to be continuing the
teachings of Enoch. So yes, new age
Luciferians quote Enoch freely and often
referring to him as a prototype of the
light bearer.
Helena Bllovski in her see the secret
doctrine in of 1888
and also in ISIS unveiled of 1877
glor she says
[clears throat]
I'm sorry it says glorified she
glorified the watchers fallen angels as
heavenly teachers is what she called
them she called Enoch himself the first
adept
who was teaching secret cosmic wisdom.
And when you really look at that, it's
pure gnostic mysticism.
Anton Leave who wrote the Satanic Bible
in 1969
adopted Enoch's themes of angelic
rebellion and enlightenment through
forbidden wisdom as the philosophical
core of Satanism because he then created
the church of Satan from what he knew.
in Cabalistic mysticism. You also have
Gersam Schulam.
I suppose this is from his book Cabala
and Moish Adidel in Cabala New
Perspectives in 1988 that show how
Enoch's angelic hierarchies became
templates
for mystical ascent which is man
climbing toward divinity through Christ.
Sorry, without Christ is the truth. All
these systems use Enoch as a manual for
angelic wisdom and knowledge. The very
thing God condemned in Deuteronomy 18
and 1 Corinthians 10 verse 20.
Scripture says that Satan himself
transforms into an angel of light in 2
Corinthians 11:14.
Enoch's angels claim to bring
enlightenment, but God calls them
rebels.
Those same watchers, as they call them
in the book of Enoch, that Enoch
glorifies are bound for judgment in Jude
6 and second Peter 2 verse4.
The book of Enoch is blatantly admitted
in these Luciferian systems, but hidden
from the masses. I found that these
occult factions often cite, quote, and
venerate Enoch. Not as scripture, of
course, but as a sacred text of hidden
knowledge. They don't hide it from each
other. They hide it from you and the
general public, the uninitiated, and the
body of Christ.
Let's break it down a little bit more
and see who admits it and how. In
Freemasonry, many Masonic rights openly
reference the royal ark of Enoch, as
they call it.
Um, Albert Pike, author of morals and
dogma, referenced Enochian legends and
sacred geometry passed down from quote
unquote antiquity.
In the Scottish right, Enoch is
considered the originator of the secret
Masonic vault which says said to contain
the name of God, lost wisdom, sacred
geometry and in some degrees Enoch is
considered the first Freemason
taught by angels.
So yes, Freemasonry openly venerates
Enoch, but only in their inner degrees.
In Cabala or Jewish mysticism, we see
that the Zohar and other mystical Jewish
writings reference the book of Enoch and
the secrets hidden given to him by
angels.
Enoch is viewed as the prototype of
Medatron. This is a very interesting
twist. Medatron is quote is said to be
the archangel who becomes divine and
sits at God's side.
Cabalists teach that Enoch was
transformed into light, received cosmic
measurements, and understood the divine
structure called a sepharat.
We will get into that a little more. But
Enoch is revered as the first recipient
of what they say
in quotations, recipient of the path of
light in Cabala.
So the Cabalists openly teach Enoch as
foundational.
They just wrap it in Hebrew terminology
and mystical allegory.
[snorts]
In alchemy, it is referred to as the
negretto albto rubto transformation. Now
don't get hung up on those words,
please. We will be explaining that and
getting it down to a little bit simpler
understanding. But this transformation
is a cycle that aligns with Enoch's
description of angelic descent and
hidden fire/ light from heaven.
Hermes
Tris
Meest, that's my best shot at that. The
mystical father of alchemy is often
synretized with Enoch. He is combined,
in other words, with Enoch. Many
esoteric writers equate the two together
as one.
Renaissance alchemists openly studied
the book of Enoch alongside the Cabala,
Egyptian texts, Gnostic gospels. So yes,
alchemists cite Enoch as the origin of
angelic wisdom and knowledge, especially
metal work, astrology and sacred fire
[snorts] with Enochian magic made by
John D and a cult and used in a cult
orders. John D. First of all, let's
understand John D was adviser to Queen
Elizabeth I developed he who developed
Enochian language and received it from
quote unquote angels.
The system is used in the Golden Dawn
used in the order
Otto
made by Alistister Cwley. It's
referenced in Luciferian sex magic and
ritual practice.
And the keys of Enoch is what they call
them, are chanted in rituals to invoke
spirits and access angelic dimensions.
That's their words.
So Enoch is the literal centerpiece of a
cult magical systems. Again, magic with
a K, especially those tied to power,
ritual, and demon invocation.
In modern pop culture and secret
societies, we see that occult books,
movies, and anime reference
the book of Enoch as containing hidden
truth the church tries to suppress.
In conspiracy circles, they twist Enoch
into an awakening text pushing Gnostic
ideas of secret divine knowledge.
Illuminati based teachings treat Enoch
as a proto Lucifer, the one who received
the hidden wisdom that man that made man
into God.
But here is a catch.
Like I said, they do not promote Enoch
to the masses as evil. They promote it
as lost truth. They present it as the
book they didn't want you to read.
And that's how they bait believers
intonosticism
and Luciferian thought. They use Enoch
as a gateway drug almost. So yes, they
absolutely admit it, venerate it, and
base their doctrines, rituals, and
systems on it. They do not. The only
thing is they just don't broadcast it on
the surface. They hide it in their
temples, in their oaths, their books,
and their upper degrees until you're too
deep to turn around.
Do they blatantly admit it? Yes,
blatantly, openly, and shamelessly. But
only to those with eyes to see. That's
their motto. Only those who are
initiated in the higher degrees with
eyes to finally be able to see and
understand. You have to work your way up
the ranks
because they hide it in what they
believe are occulted truths,
which is meaning also hidden in plain
sight.
Let's break it down a little further.
So, Freemasonry, Cabala, Lucifer, and
the Book of Enoch. Let's hear it in
their own words, shall we?
Number one, Cabala as the core of
Freemasonry. Albert Pike, a 33deree
Scottish right Freemason said in morals
and dogma, I quote, "All truly dogmatic
religions have issued from the Cabala
and return to it. Everything scientific
and grand in the religious dreams of all
the Illuminati,
all the Masonic associations owe to it
their secrets and their symbols."
In other words, Freemasonry equals
Cabala. And Cabala is about reversing
the true God's order through the
serpent's path called the
quiloth or shells, the darkened version
of the tree of life, just like new age
andnosticisnosticism.
Now, I mentioned the sepharat.
It is the tree of life in the cabala and
chakras in the new age and yoga and all
these things. Um, and how you work your
way up those areas of the tree of life
to get enlightenment.
The book of Enoch,
their proof for ascension through
forbidden knowledge. O cultists of
course like Helena Bllovadsky we as we
saw the se the oh goodness the
theosophical society the hermetic order
of the golden dawn the modern freemasons
treat the book of Enoch as essential
because it shows angels teaching
forbidden arts to mankind like alchemy
astrology enchantments weaponry makeup
and root cutting
idolize this fall that's what we have to
understand is in the occult
using the Gnostic teachings. They
idolize this fall of humankind. They
don't see it as a sin but divine
rebellion instead. They believe Lucifer
was right and the book of Enoch proves
that the angels gave man the tools to
become gods.
In their twisted view, Genesis 6 plus
the book of Enoch equals the great
liberation of man from Yahweh's
oppressive law.
Okay,
so this is purnosticism as I said and
Luciferian doctrine. They quote Enoch
because it validates quote unquote their
belief in transhuman apotheiois, the
alchemy of man into God. Again, the same
lie from Eden.
Now, we get very deep into this. A cube
within a cube and it's admitted. Now you
I know this doesn't make any sense quite
yet, but in the Jewish cabalists with
them and the Islamic mystics and a cult
Freemasons, they all teach that the cube
is Saturn and that black
uh black cube worship, which is the
kabah,
the teflon, which would be the black box
that the the Jews wear in Israel or
I guess wherever they may wear that on
their heads using black robes and the
cube tube of Mecca that they all walk
around in a circle such as other
monuments around the world all over too
is a key to controlling time, matter,
and spirit.
as they call it the inner cube seen in
elite architecture like Apple's glass
cube in New York City is their way of
saying only the initiated know the true
core the black sun or sat Saturn's
hidden light which is Lucifer
Freemasons admit they are builders in
their own words trying to complete the
quote unquote unfinished pyramid of the
tower of Babel,
not just like physically but spiritually
through alchemy and secret knowledge.
The final thing that also hit me is that
they claim that when you understand
these layers, the math and the geometry,
the architecture, the energy grids, the
black cube, the planetary gods, you will
become a god. These angels have a future
foretold in the Bible, however, that we
need to actually perk up and listen to.
In Jude 1:6,
it says, "And the the angels which kept
not their first estate, but left their
own habitation,
he hath reserved in everlasting chains
under darkness unto the judgment of the
great day." So those who left heaven and
decided to not follow God the Father and
Jesus.
[laughter]
They will be in everlasting chains until
the last day where they'll be judged and
then burned up in fire to ashes
just like the wicked on earth that God
will judge on the last day of judgment.
In 2 Peter 2:4, we also see that it
says, "For if God spared not the angels
that sinned, but cast them down to hell
and delivered them into chains of
darkness to be reserved unto judgment."
I cut it off there. So basically, if
he's going to even cast these angels and
judge them, why wouldn't he do them to
anybody else? Isn't that a great
statement? Like he is going to even
punish the angels for going weward that
did.
He will always get revenge for you. But
interestingly enough, it has connections
with Medatron. We mentioned it once. Now
we're going to answer the question, who
is Medatron completely? Medatron is a
powerful myth my mythical angelic figure
found primarily in Jewish mystical texts
particularly the Cabala and the
Babylonian Talmud.
He is not mentioned in the canonical
Jewish or Christian Bibles. However, he
is described as God's celestial scribe
who records human human deeds and is
sometimes identified as the human
prophet Enoch.
Did you hear that? All of a sudden, this
is a connection. He is said to be
identified as a human prophet Enoch
after his ascent to heaven.
That's not mentioned in the Bible.
This is just weird. It's like
considered. It says considered one of
the most powerful angels. Medatron
serves as a guide,
a mediator between God and humanity and
is sometimes called the prince of the
presence.
[snorts] He is not mentioned in the
canonical Bible but appears in texts
like the Talmud, Cabala and other
mystical writings. In some mystical
texts, Medatron is controversially
referred to as the lesser Yahweh. So now
we have a huge twisting of things. His
identity and origins are a subject of
debate in these mystical traditions with
a full story claiming that he is the
prophet Enoch who was transformed into
an angel. He's also known by several
titles including the scribe of God who
records all the deeds of humanity. The
prince of the presence who serves as a
celestial advocate or mediator between
God and humanity. See right there you
know that angels are not our mediators
ever.
Jesus is our mediator who brings our
prayers to the father.
And if that is the biblical truth then
this is directly opposing the Bible.
He's also called the king of the angels
who holds a position of immense power
and wisdom sometimes described as second
only to God.
in Hebrew numerology
which finds the numerical value of
medatron to be equal to one of the
divine names which is shadai.
So this is
yeah it's not being it's being twisted
and shown as a godly thing but it is
not.
So here we want to see directly in the
bible doctrinal issues here. The first
one is in 1 Enoch 6-7. It claims 200
angels, the watchers descended and took
wives from human women producing hybrid
children called Nephilim.
But in the Bible, directly across from
it on my right, it says in Matthew
22:30,
Jesus said, "For in the resurrection,
they neither marry nor are given in
marriage, but are like the angels of God
in heaven." This would tell you that
angels down below, let's just read what
was below. Angels are spirit beings in
Hebrew 1:14, not flesh. They do not
marry or reproduce is what this tells
us.
Scripture nowhere shows angels taking
human form to produce offspring.
This would mean that they can't produce
offspring. In other words, either
this directly contradicts Jesus's own
words and turns angels into fleshly
beings capable of carnal sin, a teaching
that is foreign to the Bible.
The second thing we see is in 1 Enoch
22, which depicts the embodied spirits
of the dead as conscious and shale
already feeling torment or reward before
judgment
taking taken over hell by an angel. He
is showing I'm sorry what I meant by
that even though it's a short note is
that Enoch was taken over hell by an
angel supposedly in the book of Enoch.
He has shown people being burned.
But in the Bible, we see in Ecclesiastes
9:5, it says, "For the living know that
they shall die, but the dead know not
anything."
This means that the dead stay in the
ground and they do not get their re
reward either to be in heaven or in hell
until the day of the second coming of
Christ or the judgment.
In 1 Thessalonians 4:16, it also says,
"The dead in Christ shall rise first."
So that's exactly what I was saying. All
the dead
stay in the ground. They do not go
straight to hell or to heaven.
The Bible teaches that death is a state
of unconscious sleep until the
resurrection and judgment. That is John
5 28-29 and Hebrews 9 27.
See, all of this,
it mirrors pagan afterlife mythology and
contradicts scriptures teachings that
all await resurrection, both righteous
and wicked do. At the end,
they will get their rewards.
But first Enoch 7-8 also shows us that
expands Genesis into a myth of celestial
beings impregnating women to produce
giants who devour mankind.
In the Bible in Genesis 6:4,
there were giants in the earth in those
days. It says the same became mighty men
which were of old,
men of renown.
Now, we need to look at this word sons
of God in the Bible, which refers to the
godly line. This is where some people
trip up. They need to understand where
Enoch comes from.
Son of God, sons of God, sorry, refers
to the godly line of Seth, intermaring
with the ungodly line of Cain, producing
powerful wicked men. That's actually
what the Bible means, not angelic
hybrids of any kind, in which they also
had an Enoch. And what I mean by that is
there was
we need to look at this because there
was an Enoch in Cain's line and there
was an Enoch in Seth's godly line. We
will be getting to that very soon. The
Hebrew phrase Benha Elohim can mean
covenant men, not angels in Deuteronomy
14:1.
Now, as we look back onto the left side
down below the Bible verse, second
paragraph, it says, "This paganized
story of angels impregnating women to
produce giants who devour mankind blends
mythology and a cult hybrid lore,
distorting the biblical account of human
sin into an angelic breeding
experiment."
Enoch, here we go. Enoch, the son of
Cain, in Genesis 4, was known for
building a city named after him,
representing a line of worldly progress.
And here's where we get the godly Enoch,
not to be confused with the other one,
and Enoch, son of Jared, in Genesis 5,
the famous patriarch who walked with God
and was taken to heaven, symbolizing
righteousness and divine favor.
If anything, the patriarch who walked
with God every day would not be writing
these things that
have occult messages and contradict the
Bible and God's teachings.
So for me, I can only conclude that the
Enoch, if it at all it was an Enoch that
did write the book of Enoch and wasn't
just somebody putting that name on there
to trick people, was the ungodly and
evil Enoch that let me go back one more
that was from the line of Cain as we saw
who was all about building and taking
over and conquest,
not the Enoch that walked with God.
Okay. So, 1 Enoch 13-15
says
or portrays Enoch as interceding for the
fallen angels pleading their case before
God. That would never happen you guys.
It's not going to happen. And in the
Bible, it says 1 Timothy 2:5, "For there
is one God and one mediator between God
and men, the man Christ Jesus."
Okay. The Bible declares that Christ
alone is the mediator and intercessor
for both men and angels in Hebrews 7
verse 25. [snorts]
So underneath my verse for first Enoch
on the left, second paragraph, it says,
"This elevates," this is what I found.
This elevates a man,
the book of Enoch does, into a mediating
role reserved only for Christ, usurping
Christ, his divine office and twisting
the order of salvation that we now see
in the Bible.
And the book of Enoch offers no mention
of Christ, Jesus, grace, or the cross.
It presents righteousness as obtained by
understanding hidden mysteries,
celestial laws, and the watchers
judgments, the fallen angels, a
works-based esoteric path utterly
opposed to salvation by faith that is
teach taught in the Bible.
This is shown in Acts 4:12 where it
says, "Neither is there salvation in any
other, for there is none other name
under heaven given among men whereby we
must be saved." The true gospel centers
on faith in Jesus that is biblical, his
sacrifice, and not on secret knowledge
or angelic visions.
So to conclude for this, these aren't
minor differences from the book of Enoch
to the Bible. They are huge theological
opposites.
It's not lost scripture that they claim
to that it is when they tell you,
whoever it might be, that you need to
read the book of Enoch to understand the
Bible better. It's a counterfeit gospel
dressed in ancient robes.
The final word is why no Christian
should touch it. And that's what I came
to know is that the book of Enoch is not
history. It's a cult theology disguised
as ancient prophecy. It teaches
salvation by secret knowledge, which is
only usually a telltale sign of a secret
society or an oult system
that is satanic at the root and
glorifies rebellion and has been
weaponized by every major cult order
from Crowley's the Lima to modern
witchcraft and gnostic mysticism. It's
not extra scripture, it's actually extra
sorcery.
My
advice is to stay in the word of God
alone. The one revelation that leads to
life, not light from fallen angels.
It says in Isaiah 8 verse 20, to the law
and to the testimony. If they speak not
according to this word, it is because
there is no light in them. And that is
what I found is that there is not light
in the book of Enoch. The Watchers
didn't enlighten mankind. They enslaved
it through teaching them how to sin. And
the book of Enoch still does the same to
anyone who opens it looking for truth
outside the word of God.
I believe that is where I'm at.
And that is my entire slide. I hope that
you guys are
are taking this all in understanding
where I'm coming from because
I actually came from a good place on
this. I did not know
that
like anything about the book of Enoch
before. I researched it from beginning
to end and everywhere that I usually do
and um
it is
coming from a non-biased um point like
that. This is what I found and so it's
very helpful
and I really
I really hope it is helpful for other
people as well. So, thank you guys for
tuning in. Um
as you know, like I said, we're
traveling. It's a little hard to present
all of this right now, but thank you so
much you guys for tuning in and hearing
what I have to say on this. I hope
you're blessed and I guess we will see
you guys another time. Thank you.
Bye-bye.